[Música]
se produjeron los primeros
enfrentamientos en quitó entre la
policía ecuatoriana y los indígenas en
el tercer día de protestas el primer
grupo de manifestantes llegó a la
capital para rechazar el alza de los
precios y las autoridades reaccionaron
con la fuerza
la policía de brasil asegura haber
encontrado los restos del periodista
británico sam phillips y del experto
bruno araújo pereira desaparecidos desde
el 5 de junio en la amazonía sin embargo
el ministro de justicia- anderson torres
les hizo que los cuerpos todavía no han
sido plenamente identificados
la reserva federal estadounidense subió
las tasas de interés en 75 puntos
básicos es el incremento más alto que ha
tomado de una sola vez desde 1994 pero
la política monetaria podría
desencadenar una recesión
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle en quito la
policía se enfrentó a los manifestantes
el miércoles cuando los primeros
indígenas llegaron a la capital
ecuatoriana aunque la llegada masiva se
espera para el viernes en el tercer día
de protestas arriba el primer grupo
convocado por la poderosa confederación
de nacionalidades indígenas quienes
protestan en contra del alza de los
precios las autoridades respondieron con
la fuerza mientras el ministerio del
interior sostiene que tendrá controlada
la situación
nosotros tenemos control sobre la
situación respecto de las personas que
están ingresando a la ciudad y podemos
garantizar que con tendremos la
violencia con el uso progresivo con la
firmeza que requiere el ecuador pero
trataremos de proteger a la mayoría de
ciudadanos que quiere vivir en
democracia y que quiere convivir en paz
la policía federal de brasil afirmó que
encontraron los restos del periodista
británico don phillips y del experto
indigenista bruno araújo pereira esto
luego de que los dos principales
sospechosos confesaron haberlos
asesinado y uno de los acusados viajará
a la amazonía con las autoridades para
identificar el lugar donde supuestamente
los enterraron sin embargo el ministerio
de justicia brasileño precisó que los
cuerpos todavía no han sido reconocidos
esto es lo que dijo la policía
nuestro
anoche logramos que el primer sospechoso
detenido en este caso un hombre conocido
como pelado
el señor amarillo voluntariamente
confesar el crimen
durante la confesión en presencia de
diputados de la policía federal civil y
miembros del grupo de trabajo
narró detalladamente y señaló donde
había enterrado los cuerpos
cuál es a propósito de este caso que ha
conmovido a brasil y al mundo alva
santana nos trae más detalles en el
siguiente reporte
entre muchas dudas sobre qué pasó con el
indigenista bruno araujo y el periodista
phillips en la amazonía brasileña los
investigadores están un paso más cerca
de conocer la verdad después de que dos
de los principales sospechosos por su
desaparición confesaron haber
participado en su asesinato
[Música]
el pescador amarillo duda costa alias
pelado reconoció haber quemado sus
cuerpos junto a su hermano pero aseguró
que fue una tercera persona que los
asesinó el periodista británico don
phillips y el experto indigenista bruno
araujo pereira trabajaban en una
investigación cuando el 5 de junio
partieron de la comunidad desahoga fai
atalaya del norte en el valle de javarí
un viaje de aproximadamente tres horas
que nunca terminó para ellos pasaron por
la comunidad de sao gabriel donde vive
amaré a toda costa y se les vio por
última vez en la comunidad de la calle
era cerca de donde encontraron a sus
pertenencias esta región de la amazonía
es vecina de perú y colombia- y cuenta
con el mayor número de comunidades
indígenas incomunicadas pero también se
caracteriza por su peligrosidad debido
al narcotráfico la caza furtiva y la
minería y la maderería ilegal la
situación de los nuestros colegas
y esta es la situación de nuestros
colegas expertos indígenas en la zona es
desesperante están en sobrecarga en
shock agotados necesitan todo el apoyo
al igual que los indígenas especies ante
todo apoyo
así como los indígenas preciso
urgentemente
necesitamos urgentemente el despliegue
de fuerzas del orden para garantizar la
seguridad en esta región fronteriza
frontera las autoridades sospechan que
el móvil del asesinato está relacionado
con la pesca ilegal en la zona en
especial de un pez protegido el pirarucú
aunque aún faltan por confirmar los
detalles de la autoría del crimen
pasamos a colombia los candidatos
presidenciales de la segunda vuelta
electoral tendrán que asistir a un
debate así lo ordenó el tribunal
superior de bogotá que además precisó
que la discusión pública debe darse a
más tardar el jueves 16 de junio y es
que el populista rodolfo hernández se
había negado a debatir con su contendor
izquierdista gustavo petro en esta
segunda parte de las elecciones pero
ahora por orden de un juez deberá
defender sus propuestas abiertamente
antes del balotaje del próximo domingo
19 de julio
en noticias de eeuu la reserva federal
anunció que incrementará su tasa de
interés en 75 puntos básicos es la
subida más alta que ha habido en una
sola vez desde 1994 la fed explicó que
la medida es para bajar la histórica
inflación que enfrenta el país aunque la
política monetaria agresiva podría
llevar a una recesión les explicamos en
el siguiente informe
con la inflación en su punto más alto en
los últimos 40 años
la reserva federal realizó el miércoles
su más agresiva subida de tipos de
interés en casi tres décadas subiendo
los en 75 puntos básicos widget en la
reserva federal entendemos las
dificultades que está causando la alta
inflación y estamos firmemente
comprometidos con la reducción de la
inflación y nos estamos moviendo
rápidamente para hacerlo de uso subiendo
los tipos de interés la fe te espera que
los consumidores ahorren en lugar de
gastar ayudando a mantener la inflación
bajo control en mayo la inflación anual
alcanzó el 8,6 por ciento y los
consumidores están sintiendo las
consecuencias
los estadounidenses lamentan el aumento
de los costes de vivienda la energía los
combustibles y el combustible
gastamos como más de 100 dólares por un
tanque de gasolina es lo más alto que
hemos tenido nunca y además el precio de
los alimentos todo sube básicamente clic
al shabab el aumento de los tipos de
interés conlleva un riesgo si el banco
central se excede la economía podría
ralentizarse hasta el punto de provocar
una recesión impulsando el desempleo
y estamos viendo señales de estrés en
los hogares de bajos ingresos y estamos
viendo que la confianza del consumidor
comienza a colapsar y el mismo hemos
visto una contracción en lo que respecta
a las ventas minoristas así que creo que
es un aterrizaje brusco y una recesión
en eeuu es inevitable
y neretva se espera que la subida de los
tipos de interés no contribuya a reducir
los costos cotidianos de los
consumidores al menos no inmediatamente
el repunte de los precios mundiales de
los alimentos y la energía- se debe en
gran medida a la invasión rusa en
ucrania que está fuera del control de la
fed
el departamento de justicia
estadounidense acusó al autor de la
reciente masacre ocurrida en la ciudad
de buffalo en el estado de nueva york-
el imputado recibió 26 cargos por
delitos de odio y uso de armas de fuego
26 cargos por delitos de odio y uso de
armas de fuego este es el número de
acusaciones que enfrenta a peyton game
round el joven de 18 años que perpetró
la masacre de búfalo el departamento de
justicia estadounidense imputó
formalmente al joven calificado de
supremacista este miércoles el fiscal
general de eeuu de visita en el lugar
del tiroteo dio a conocer la noticia de
after en la declaración jurada en apoyo
de la denuncia cita al acusado afirmando
que su objetivo era matar tantos negros
como fuera posible la declaración jurada
describe como el acusado se preparó
durante meses para llevar a cabo este
ataque
algunas de estas imputaciones pueden ser
condenadas con la pena máxima
primero por supuesto tiene que haber una
acusación después de la acusación se
seguirán los procedimientos
reglamentarios y se consultará a las
familias ya los supervivientes las
denuncias a kenton consisten en diez
cargos por cometer un crimen de odio con
resultado de muerte tres cargos por
intento de asesinato
diez cargos por usar un arma de fuego
para cometer un asesinato durante y en
relación con un delito de violencia y
tres cargos de uso y descarga de un arma
de fuego durante un delito de violencia
el pasado 14 de mayo peyton gran dron
viajó hasta el supermercado tops de la
localidad de buffalo con un casco
militar una cámara y fuertemente armado
con un equipamiento táctico asesinó a 10
personas afroamericanas jenson fue
sometido a exámenes psiquiátricos al
manifestar una conducta suicida pero el
personal que lo trató consideró que no
suponía ningún peligro a la sociedad el
tiroteo de búfalo se sumó a una serie de
hechos mortales que dejaron decenas de
fallecidos como la matanza y duval de
texas que avivaron el debate sobre el
porte y control de armas en el país y
terminamos en mexico una de las nietas
del nobel colombiano gabriel garcía
márquez encontró más de 150 cartas que
líderes mundiales le enviaron en su
momento al escritor algunas de las
misivas fueron enviadas por el ex
presidente estadounidense bill clinton
el líder cubano fidel castro y el vocero
zapatista marcos emilia garcía elizondo
directora de la casa de la literatura de
la fundación gabriel garcía márquez y
nieta del escritor dijo que el hallazgo
se produjo cuando buscaban una
fotografía para conmemorar el
aniversario número 40 del premio nobel
las cartas estaban en una caja que tenía
la etiqueta con la palabra ni ellos
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con france
[Música]